did lucas alberto and souls 22 end up in
toronto is abby boo from monsters inc
and could this be a panda villain may
fights and a turning red sequel yipikai
movie lovers i'm jan and in this video
we're taking a deep dive into some
mind-blowing fan theories about turning
red plus some new characters and stories
we could see in a sequel or disney plus
series abby one of my favorite
characters in turning red is at the
center of a popular fan theory that
she's actually boo from monsters inc
fans have noticed numerous similarities
between the two characters for example
just like boo's strong attraction to the
fairy sully abby is instantly drawn to
may's red panda when she first meets
her fluffy then there's a strong
resemblance in the five petal flower
decorations on abby's dungarees and the
pattern on boo's door in monsters inc
both abby's clothes and the door also
have a similar pinky purply and pastel
colour palette going on on top of that
they have a similar shaped face brown
eyes hair colour and bangs now rather
than abby actually being boo herself i
think a more likely possibility is that
boo is abby's younger sister something
that would fit the timeline of both
movies better in monsters inc one of the
files that mike opens up indicates the
monsters are scaring kids in 1999 and we
know from various moments in turning red
that that movie takes place in 2002.
boo's around two years old in monsters
inc which would make her around five at
the time of turning red and credit to
the carlin brothers who spotted that the
area of the world the monsters are
scaring in lines up roughly with toronto
canada if abby and boo are sisters then
it would make sense that they share some
similar features and maybe personality
traits like i mentioned before and given
the t-shirt this kid was at abby's
school i think pixar are strongly
hinting that monsters inc exists in the
world of turning red also as abby's
sister boo would certainly know about
may and her family's transformations and
as the sister of one of may's friends
she could easily visit the temple and
learn more about red panda magic and
even how to access alternate realms like
the astral plane for pixar theorists
this would bolster the idea that buu
learns to time travel and becomes the
witch in brave a key tenet of john
negroni's pixar theory that proposes all
of pixar's movies exist in an
interconnected universe
after pixar released the movie soul a
popular fan theory arose that when 22
finally went to earth she would become
the main character in turning red who we
now know of course is mei lin and one of
our amazing movie lovers ns67 asked me
if i could comment on whether this was
still likely it's true that maymay is
both confident and sassy with a dash of
sarcasm similar to 22. the main issue
with this theory is that seoul appears
to take place many years after turning
red given that smartphones like the one
joe uses weren't around in 2002
countering this discrepancy though is
the idea that time in the great beyond
works differently you know time's not
really a thing here which i guess
theoretically could imply that when 22
goes to earth she arrives many years
earlier to joe in 1989 the likely year
that maelynn was born but the other
problem with this theory is that when 22
descends to earth she's headed towards
asia perhaps china and definitely not
canada it's possible that may was born
in china and then moved to toronto with
her parents when she was still a baby as
was the case with the movie's director
domi she who based much of the film on
her own experiences however it appears
that the family's red panda temple has
been in toronto a long time so this
seems unlikely our family runs one of
the oldest temples in toronto plus
according to may's father ming almost
destroyed half the toronto temple when
she transformed into a red panda when
she was younger still there is a strong
connection between the two movies via
the astral plane a realm that can be
accessed in both films by drawing a
circle and performing a chanting
ceremony so i'm not discounting the
theory entirely plus there's also the
small possibility that ming could have
given birth to may in china for example
while visiting relatives there which
would mean that baby may could have been
in the right place for 22's arrival on
earth after all one of our awesome movie
lovers goodbye had an intriguing theory
that when 22 went down to china she
actually became a red panda but also had
some human dna which gave her the
ability to change between human and
panda form and i think what they may be
implying is that 22 could have been the
original red panda spirit that gave the
lee family their powers
an interesting detail fans have noticed
is a similarity between tyler and
alberto from luca they both have a
similar hairstyle and outgoing
personality so could they be related is
what some people are wondering well luca
was set around 40 or 50 years before
turning red so if there is a connection
it could be that alberto was tyler's
grandfather for example alberto could
well have decided to follow his friend
lucas lead and leave puerto roso to end
up perhaps even in canada
another fascinating connection between
lucca and turning red is suggested by
another of our marvelous movie lovers
clark m who theorises that julia may
have had secret transformation abilities
similar to maymays like mainland who
gets red hair after becoming the red
panda julia's red hair could suggest she
also had the power to transform into a
big red creature but she decided to
conceal her abilities because of the
local prejudice in puerto rosso against
sea monsters it's an interesting thought
and given how both movies feature human
creature hybrids it certainly makes for
an entertaining theory
turning red has been disney plus's
biggest ever movie premiere to date
which is why it's no surprise that fans
have already started speculating about a
potential series or sequel and both
director domi she and producer lindsey
collins have said there's plenty of
opportunity for more turning red stories
in fact some of the unused concept art
from the movie gives us a hint of what
could happen next one idea that was
considered at pixar was that may had a
cousin who could also turn into a red
panda there was a rivalry between his
side of the family and maymays which it
seems would have led to some sort of
confrontation something i think could be
very interesting for a sequel then
there's an early version of concept art
for the origins of the red panda curse
which appears to show a male ancestor
encountering the panda spirit this idea
could be used to create another panda
spirit bloodline that passes down
through the male descendants of a
different branch of the family in
addition to the female line as happens
with melin ming grandma and the aunties
in a sequel we could also see may's
panda powers develop and grow as unlike
her mother and other relatives she's
decided to live with the panda rather
than lock it away unused concept art for
panda may shows that at one time she
would grow to different sizes depending
on just how angry excited or emotional
she was and there was the possibility
that she could even grow to become a
gigantic kaiju-like creature mayzilla
just like her mother mingzilla something
that could be very exciting to see in a
sequel may could also get firepowers in
the future or fire fur an idea that was
considered but didn't make it into the
first film and if you'd like to discover
even more scenes and characters which
were cut from the final version of the
movie and could turn up in a sequel like
the villainous benny blacktooth tap here
to watch my turning red deleted scenes
and alternate ending video there's also
a link in the video description so what
are your favorite turning red theories
and what would you like to see in a
sequel let me know in the comments below
next tap left to discover all the clues
you might have missed to the ending of
turning red and if you enjoyed this
video then do leave a thumbs up i really
appreciate it thanks for enjoying this
movie with me and hope you have a
marvellous movie-loving week yuppie kaio
movie lovers